this viral question is known as the  hardest sat problem if X and Y are  positive integers and 2x minus 4y is  equal to 3 then find the value of 16 to  the power of x divided by 256 to the  power of Y  to solve this problem 16 is equal to 4  squared and 256 is equal to 4 to the  power of 4. substitute into the  numerator and denominator and then use  exponent rules to simplify  we end up with 4 to the power of 2x  minus 4y but that exponent is equal to 3  so we have 4 to the power of 3 which is  equal to 64 and that's the apparent  answer but wait 2x minus 4y factors to  be 2 multiplied by x minus 2y for  positive integers X and Y this is an  integer which means 2 times an integer  is an even number so this can never be  equal to 3 and the correct answer is the  premise of the question is wrong we  shouldn't mindlessly be solving problems  put in front of us we should try to  think about what the correct answer  actually is